[Música]
magdalena y maría jugaban sobre un
tablero vacío y lo hacían con una sola
pieza
la tengo aquí la pieza del caballo les
habíamos pedido que intentarán resolver
el problema de euler el problema del
salto del caballo que es aquel que bueno
nos obliga a mover la pieza por todas
las casillas las 64 sin pisar dos veces
la misma casilla parece fácil pero no lo
es
esa mañana para administrar un poco la
dinámica les habíamos repartido la
magdalena de maría que jugaban en pareja
y al resto de parejas les hemos
repartido unos cuencos con unos
garbanzos y les habíamos pedido que
pusieran esas legumbres en cada una de
las casillas cuando el caballo se
quedaba sin casilla libre
la pareja se retiraba y esperaba el
resto magdalena y maría estaba muy
nerviosa su corcel había sido un poco
algo así como pulgarcito y ya
barruntaban ellas que iba a ser de toda
esa hilera de tableros el suyo el más
parecido a una huerta fértil de
leguminosas es decir que había muchos
descansos y efectivamente he hecho los
recuentos con las justas ganadoras con
53 saltos de caballo aplausos jubilosa
abrazos felicidad sincera algunos estáis
diciendo bueno pero si es un simple
juego si es un simple juego pero lo
extraordinario de esta historia es que
magdalena tiene cerca de 80 años si no
los tiene
y maría no sabe leer y no sabe escribir
ya se fueron a su casa felices radiantes
con la energía catapultadas a esos
niveles donde solo sale la autoestima el
afán de logro porque se habían dado
cuenta que eran capaces de tomar
decisiones de planificar lo que subyace
de esta entrañable historia aún
recuerdan que son las ganadoras casi
casi resuelven el problema de euless se
quedaron a 10 saltitos aún lo recuerda
pues lo interesantísimo y la pregunta
que subyace de esta entrañable historia
no es otra que la de la toma de
decisiones cómo podemos tomar decisiones
cómo podemos tomar mejores decisiones
que elementos entran en juego nunca
mejor dicho
boyle si lo vi fue un psicólogo
cognitivo que tras muchos estudia muchos
experimentos nos dijo algo muy
interesante nos dijo que para la toma de
decisiones a veces tomamos más en cuenta
nuestras emociones que nuestros juicios
y reflexiones es decir que damos
respuesta a cómo me siento y no tanto a
cómo pienso oa qué pienso esto en el
juego del ajedrez también se observa y
además de una forma muy clara
entonces qué estáis pensando pero el
juego del ajedrez no era algo reflexivo
analítico bueno sí pero no porque quién
está jugando al ajedrez sabe la tremenda
y terrible tensión que uno tiene cuando
ve un reloj que se acaba ya implacable
que te obliga a mover cuántas veces en
la vida sabemos que tenemos el turno
pero no nos atrevemos a mover porque
vamos castigando vamos dejando lo vamos
bonita se resolverá verdad en el ajedrez
esto no es posible o mueves o mueres y
si no pierdes
hay una presión brutal tenemos un
sentimiento tal que a veces movemos para
sentir alivio y ya está la jugada a lo
mejor nos lleva a la derrota pero
nosotros nos sentimos bien por eso se ve
tan claramente esto que nos decía slovik
en realidad incluso cuando nos
enfrentamos a un rival que pensamos que
es superior a nosotros esta tensión sube
mucho más y cualquier distracción
también puede influir poderosamente en
la toma de decisiones
cuentan que las care que fue un filósofo
matemático en sus ratos libres se hizo
campeón del mundo de ajedrez pues
cuentan que el azkar jugaba una partida
con infovic otro gran teórico de la
historia del nuevo juego del doble juego
y las crea un fumador empedernido estaba
el día fumando habanos en zombies
detesto detectaba no quería ni a oler el
dolor a tabaco le pidió a las que que
por favor durante la partida no fumar a
las que amablemente le dijo no te
preocupes en zombies que no voy a fumar
pero es lo que los aficionados llamamos
en el medio juego las que se sacó su
puro algunos cuentan que se lo pasaba
por la boca a otros que jugueteaba con
él entre los dedos el resto a bit
valga la broma fácil le sacaba de sus
casillas y ya no se lo hizo ver a las
que habías dicho que no ibas a fumar lo
estoy fumando y además usted maestro un
infovic me imagino que le diría en ese
tono usted maestro de infovic debería
saber que la amenaza es más fuerte que
su ejecución
y es cierto a veces nos inventamos
jáquez amenazas que no son tan reales es
decir no es tan fácil elegir una buena
decisión es tan fácil el proceso verdad
es bastante confuso porque con esta
influencia emocional que disteis lo vi
con esta presión implacable del tiempo
que es difícil bueno pues el ajedrez te
enseña algo es una herramienta que te
enseña una destreza fundamental que es
el reconocimiento de patrones
el ajedrez enseña no son las
reconocernos sino incluso a construir
patrones patrones definamos como una
serie de elementos de constantes
variables que se repiten que son
identificables y que son recurrentes
sabemos identificarlos en una partida de
ajedrez en una posición determinada si
sabemos identificar que una dama y un
alfil se han puesto de acuerdo para
operar por una misma diagonal eso nos da
confianza hemos reconocido un patrón
empezamos a soltar un poquito de la
emoción ésta a la que se refería a esta
terrible de la que hablamos porque
sabemos que esa batería que los chicos
llaman cuando empiezan a jugar al
ajedrez el trenecito a veces nos lleva
como es el ejemplo a una posición hasta
ganadora no siempre pero bueno más o
menos la suerte es que practicando con
frecuencia no vale jugar una partida
pero si lo practicamos con frecuencia la
suerte es que la gente no se enseña no
se entrena a identificar patrones porque
en la vida también existen patrones
patrones sociales imaginemos no que
estamos en visita en cualquier otro país
en otras costumbres culturas destinos
lugares reconocemos ningún patrón
algunos sí pero cuando llegamos al
aeropuerto todo no suena familiar parece
que ya hemos vuelto a mandar a los
paneles de información las puertas de
embarque esto ya me lo conozco verdad es
como casi una partida de ajedrez por la
que ya has pasado esto me suena la buena
noticia es que todas y todos los que
estamos aquí somos unos magníficos
buscadores de patrones lo hacemos por
instinto por naturaleza hemos venido a
ello pero también podemos entrenarlo y
el milenario juego nos enseña hagamos de
escazos juguemos con él porque vamos a
hacer magníficos como digo pero además
vamos a poder incluso crearlos no ha
pasado ninguna vez lo cual que sí que
cuando os habéis acercado un grupo de
amigos de repente
notas que cambia la conversación que
cambian las miradas la risa fatal y
facebook estaban hablando de mí este es
un patrón social por eso digo que somos
muy buenos en ello verdad
bueno pues somos tan magníficos que
entendemos y comprendemos la realidad
gracias a este tipo de asideros de
garantías de confianza que nos otorgan
los patrones el ajedrez te enseña a ello
un patrón ajedrecístico muy útil para
nuestra vida diaria es precisamente el
que se inspira en la enseñanza para la
comprensión una mirada educativa un tipo
de aprendizaje que emana del proyecto
zero de la universidad de harvard con
david perkins a la cabeza
y podemos verlo en un tablero de ajedrez
el tipo de pensamiento que defiende la
enseñanza para la comprensión nivel al
escalón a / es observar pensar y
preguntarse lo que deberíamos hacer en
una partida en otra posición que podemos
ver da igual que no sepáis ajedrez no
creo que sea entender perfectamente por
qué que observo un tablero de ajedrez y
unas piezas ya está de verdad todo el
mundo lo sabe que pienso sobre ello
pienso que aunque no sepa mucho las
blancas queden menos piezas y no parece
que vayan muy bien y que me pregunto
sobre ellos que me pregunto me pregunto
quién es el poseedor del turno a qué le
toca mover porque si somos blancas
podemos tomar la decisión de rendirnos
ante la clara desventaja tenemos muy
poquitas piezas verdad pero si nos toca
mover aquí estás podemos ver que con una
sola jugada hemos conseguido ganar
estas rutinas de pensamiento son tan
importantes en la vida porque nos ayudan
a llegar a regar la construcción mental
de un árbol de decisiones a tener
ramificaciones a tener opciones podemos
mejorar nuestra toma de decisiones si
nos movemos la primera que se nos pasa
por la cabeza si tenemos un árbol de
donde agarrarnos por lo menos mirar en
perspectiva las kers se acuerdan el del
puro la que nos dejó escrita una frase
que para mí es un consejo de vida las
que él dijo cuando veas una buena jugada
trata de encontrar otra mejor
siguiendo el consejo de las que me
atrevo incluso a mirar un tablero como
un espejo de la realidad
me lo permitís como una obra de arte
donde hay a escondidas muchas
informaciones que a simple vista no
vemos me gusta verlo
como le pasó a un escritor ghana turco
un novelista llamado teófila autor en
1846 visitó el museo del prado con la
única intención de contemplar las
meninas de velázquez
se puso delante del lienzo observo las
meninas
pensó sobre las meninas
quizás un largo silencio
preguntó en voz alta pero dónde está el
cuadro
riccardo yo me lo imagino me lo imagino
pensando con esa en ese paso atrás del
pintor queda velásquez en el cuadro me
lo imagino
con esa pausa que te da el juego del
ajedrez para no caer en el chantaje del
tiempo en esta urgencia 3.0 en la que
todos estamos pero me lo imagino a
walker dando ese paso atrás
tomando perspectiva encontrando una
jugada en la casilla h 8 encontrando un
secreto donde solo veía a una infanta
margarita pero luego pensando en el
atrevimiento de diego de velázquez que
de repente se mete en el cuadro que nos
mira como espectadores que no sabemos si
está pintando
al referir el cuarto con mariana de
austria que de repente se proyecta al
fondo como una especie de espejo que
quizás no es un espejo que quizás es el
tercer cuadro del cuadro
me imagino a gaultier haciendo este tipo
de disquisiciones incluso no se pensaría
que el enano bufón de la corte italiana
aquel allá que parece que está jugando
pegándole una patada a un mastín más
genérico lacito pertusato incluso que
también le llamó la atención por eso
reivindicó con la historia de ganthier
que demos un paso atrás que podamos
ganar perspectivas que ganemos
comprensión porque cuando jugamos al
ajedrez básicamente lo que estamos
haciendo es resolver problemas y tomar
decisiones que es justo lo que hacemos
todos los días de nuestras vidas
justo cuando vemos una jugada que nos
lleva al jaque mate a la victoria en
realidad estamos pisando el terreno de
la creatividad del pensamiento lateral
cuando nos anticipamos a la jugada del
otro no sabéis la felicidad que da e
incluso hay cruces de mirada dejar
adivina qué verdad que ha jugado lo sabe
cuando estamos pensando en qué vamos a
hacer ahora pero también es que vamos a
hacer a más largo plazo en un
pensamiento más estratégico estamos
trabajando en el enfoque dual
importantísimo en nuestras vidas que es
la táctica y estrategia como diría
benedetti pero por encima de cualquier
otra habilidad o destreza cognitiva yo o
socio afectiva por encima de cualquier
otra destreza surge con fuerza el
reconocimiento de los propios errores el
ajedrez te enseña a ser responsable no
vale el terreno embarrado el árbitro no
valen excusas no hay coartada posible
cada uno se hace responsable de lo que
ha movido en el tablero importante sería
transferir esa habilidad nuestro día a
día verdad
todo este tipo de reflexiones que nos
enseña que cada vez que movemos una
pieza en el tablero estamos modificando
por completo la posición así como cada
vez que actuamos en la vida estamos
modificando nuestra relación con el otro
con el entorno con nuestras familias con
esos amigos que cambiaban de
conversación que nos veían
cuando entendemos esto realmente estamos
viendo qué importancia tiene ese paso
atrás de velázquez que yo aquí hoy
quería reivindicar por esa mirada
ajedrecística esa mirada del pintor todo
este tipo de reflexiones
que esta movida está tocada está tocada
pieza movida esta responsabilidad que
tenemos en el juego del tablero cobro
todo el sentido práctico no sólo el
retórico y filosófico cuando me
invitaron el 8 de marzo de 2016 a dar
una conferencia en una cárcel de mujeres
en méjico en el estado de morelos en el
cefereso número 16 me puse delante de
200 reclusas y les hice ver y subraya la
importancia que tiene esta reflexión
no sabéis no sabéis de verdad cuando
subraya una máxima que para los
ajedrecistas es fundamental y es que una
sola mala jugada te hace perder la
partida da igual cuantas buenas hayas
hecho antes las doscientas
a las doscientas reclusas de s cefereso
a sentían como habéis hecho vosotros y
yo estoy seguro que cada una de ellas
estaba rebobinando cuál fue ese error
que de momento les hizo perder la
partida lo bueno de todo esto es que nos
quedan muchas batallas todavía muchos
juegos seguro que tenéis tableros de
ajedrez en casa escondidos vamos a
sacarlos vamos a desempolvar nos vamos a
jugar vamos a conocer mucho de nosotros
de nuestros hijos de con quien estemos
jugando
no hace falta mucho 10-15 minutos os van
a ser suficientes para entender las
reglas básicas acordaros del ejemplo de
magdalena y mariah no existe edad no
existe condición cualquiera podemos
disfrutar de él y tengamos siempre
presente que nuestra mejor jugada
que nuestro
es nuestra mejor toma de decisiones que
me están acordando de las de las presas
pero sigue porque no está mejor toma de
decisiones en este tablero ajedrezado
que es la vida aún está porque podamos
hacerla muchas gracias y buena partida
[Aplausos]